the most important gift your mother and
father ever gave you was the two sets of
three billion letters of DNA that make
up your genome but like anything with
three billion components that gift is
fragile sunlight smoking unhealthy
eating even spontaneous mistakes made by
your cells all caused changes to your
genome
the most common kind of change in DNA is
the simple swap of one letter or base
such as C with a different letter such
as T G or a in any day the cells in your
body will collectively accumulate
billions of these single letter swaps
which are also called point mutations
now most of these point mutations are
harmless but every now and then a point
mutation disrupts an important
capability in a cell or causes a cell to
misbehave in harmful ways if that
mutation were inherited from your
parents or occurred early enough in your
development then the result would be
that many or all of your cells contain
this harmful mutation and then you would
be one of hundreds of millions of people
with a genetic disease such as sickle
cell anemia or progeria or muscular
dystrophy or tay-sachs disease grievous
genetic diseases caused by point
mutations are especially frustrating
because we often know the exact single
letter change that causes the disease
and in theory could cure the disease
millions suffer from sickle cell anemia
because they have a single ATT point
mutations in both copies of their
hemoglobin gene and children with
progeria are born with a T at a single
position in their genome where you have
a C with the devastating consequence
that these wonderful bright kids age
very rapidly and pass away by about age
throughout the history of Medicine we
have not had a way to efficiently
correct point mutations in living
systems to change that disease-causing T
back into a C perhaps until now because
my laboratory recently succeeded in
developing such a capability which we
call base editing the story of how we
developed base editing actually begins
three billion years ago we think of
bacteria as sources of infection but
bacteria themselves are also prone to
being infected in particular by viruses
so about three billion years ago
bacteria evolved a defense mechanism to
fight viral infection that defense
mechanism is now better known as CRISPR
and the warhead and CRISPR is this
purple protein that acts like molecular
scissors to cut DNA breaking the double
helix into two pieces
if CRISPR couldn't distinguish between
bacterial and viral DNA it wouldn't be a
very useful defense system but the most
amazing feature of CRISPR is that the
scissors can be programmed to search for
bind to and cut only a specific DNA
sequence so when a bacterium encounters
a virus for the first time it can store
a small snippet of that virus's DNA for
use as a program to direct the CRISPR
scissors to cut that viral DNA sequence
during a future infection cutting of
virus's DNA messes up the function of
the cut viral gene and therefore
disrupts the virus's life cycle
remarkable researchers including Emanuel
sharp NTA George Church Jennifer Doudna
and funn John showed six years ago
how CRISPR scissors could be programmed
to cut DNA sequences of our choosing
including sequences in your genome
instead of the viral DNA sequences
chosen by bacteria but the outcomes are
actually similar cutting a DNA sequence
in your genome also disrupts the
function of the cut
gene typically by causing the insertion
and deletion of random mixtures of DNA
letters at the cut site now disrupting
genes can be very useful for some
applications but for most point
mutations that cause genetic diseases
simply cutting the already mutated gene
won't benefit patients because the
function of the mutated gene needs to be
restored not further disrupted so
cutting this already mutated hemoglobin
gene that causes sickle cell anemia
won't restore the ability of patients to
make healthy red blood cells and while
we can sometimes introduce new DNA
sequences into cells to replace the DNA
sequences surrounding a cut site that
process unfortunately doesn't work in
most types of cells and the disrupted
gene outcomes still predominate like
many scientists I've dreamed of a future
in which you might be able to treat or
maybe even cure human genetic diseases
but I saw the lack of a way to fix point
mutations which caused most human
genetic diseases as a major problem
standing in the way being a chemist I
began working with my students to
develop ways on performing chemistry
directly on an individual DNA base to
truly fix rather than disrupt the
mutations that cause genetic diseases
the results of our efforts are molecular
machines called base editors base
editors use the programmable searching
mechanism of CRISPR scissors but instead
of cutting the DNA they directly convert
one base to another base without
disrupting the rest of the gene so if
you think of naturally-occurring CRISPR
proteins as molecular scissors you can
think of base editors as pencils capable
of directly rewriting one DNA letter
into another by actually rearranging the
atoms of one DNA base to instead become
a different base now base editors don't
exist in nature
in fact we engineered the first base
editor
Joan herre from three separate proteins
that don't even come from the same
organism we started by taking crisper
scissors and disabling the ability to
cut DNA while retaining its ability to
search for and bind a target DNA
sequence in a programmed manner to those
disabled CRISPR scissors shown in blue
we attached a second protein in red
which performs a chemical reaction on
the DNA base see converting it into a
base that behaves like T third we had to
attach to the first two proteins the
proteins shown in purple which protects
the edited base from being removed by
the cell the net result is an engineered
three-part protein that for the first
time allows us to convert C's entities
at specified locations in the genome but
even at this point our work was only
half done because in order to be stable
in cells the two strands of the DNA
double helix have to form base pairs and
because see only pairs with G and T only
pairs with a simply changing a C to a T
on one DNA strand creates a mismatch a
disagreement between the two DNA strands
that the cell has to resolve by deciding
which strand to replace we realize that
we could further engineer this
three-part protein to flag the non
edited strand as the one to be replaced
by nicking that strand this little NIC
tricks the cell into replacing the non
edited G with an A as it remakes the
nicked strand
thereby completing the conversion of
what used to be a CG base pair into a
stable T a base pair after several years
of hard work led by a former postdoc in
the lab Alexis Co more we succeeded in
developing this first class of base
editor which converts sees into T's and
G's into A's at targeted positions of
our choosing among the more than 35,000
disease-associated point mutations the
two kinds of mutations that this
first-base editor can reverse
collectively account for about 14% or
5,000 or so pathogenic point mutations
but correcting the largest fraction of
disease-causing point mutations would
require developing a second class of
base editor one that could convert A's
into G's or T's into C's led by Nicole
Goodell II a former postdoc in the lab
we set out to develop this second class
of base editor which in theory could
correct up to almost half of pathogenic
point mutations including that mutation
that causes the rapid aging disease
progeria we realized that we could
borrow
once again the targeting mechanism of
Chris furred scissors to bring the new
base editor to the right site in a
genome but we quickly encountered an
incredible problem namely there is no
protein that's known to convert a into G
or T into see in DNA faced with such a
serious stumbling block most students
would probably look for another project
if not another research advisor but
Nicole agreed to proceed with a plan
that seemed wildly ambitious at the time
given the absence of a naturally
occurring protein that performs the
necessary chemistry we decided we would
evolve our own protein in the laboratory
to convert a into a base that behaves
like G starting from a protein that
performs related chemistry on RNA we set
up a Darwinian survival of the fittest
selection system that explored tens of
millions of protein variants and only
allowed those rare variants that could
perform the necessary chemistry to
survive we ended up with a protein shown
here the first that can convert a in DNA
into a base that resembles G and when we
attach that protein to the disable of
CRISPR scissors shown in blue we
produced the second base editor which
converts
a is into Gees and then uses the same
strand nicking strategy that we used in
the first base editor to trick the cell
into replacing the non edited T with a C
as it remakes that nicked strand thereby
completing the conversion of an eighty
base pair to a GC base pair thank you as
a academic scientist in the US and not
used to being interrupted by applause
we developed these first two classes of
base editors only three years ago and
one and a half years ago but even that
short time base editing has become
widely used by the biomedical research
community base editors have been sent
more than six thousand times at the
request of more than one thousand
researchers around the globe a hundred
scientific research papers have been
published already using base editors in
organisms ranging from bacteria to
plants to mice to primates while base
editors are too new to have already
entered human clinical trials scientists
have succeeded in achieving a critical
milestone towards that goal by using
base editors in animals to correct point
mutations that cause human genetic
diseases for example a collaborative
team of scientists led by Luc koblan and
John levy two additional students in my
lab recently used a virus to deliver
that second base editor into a mouse
with progeria changing that
disease-causing T back into a C and
reversing its consequences at the DNA
RNA and protein levels base editors have
also been used in animals to reverse the
consequence of tyrosinemia beta
thalassemia muscular dystrophy
phenylketonuria a congenital deafness
and a type of cardiovascular disease in
each case by directly correcting a point
mutation that causes or contributes to
the disease in plants bass editors have
been used to introduce individuals
single DNA letter changes that could
lead to better crops and biologists have
used bass editors to probe the role of
individual letters in genes associated
with diseases such as cancer to
companies I co-founded beam therapeutics
and pairwise plants are using bass
editing to treat human genetic diseases
and to improve agriculture all of these
applications of bass
have taken place in less than the past
three years on the historical timescale
of science the blink of an eye
additional work lies ahead before base
editing can realize its full potential
to improve the lives of patients with
genetic diseases while many of these
diseases are thought to be treatable by
correcting the underlying mutation in
even a modest fraction of cells in an
organ delivering molecular machines like
base Editors into cells in a human being
can be challenging co-opting nature's
viruses to deliver base Editors instead
of the molecules that give you a cold is
one of several promising delivery
strategies that's been successfully used
continuing to develop new molecular
machines that can make all of the
remaining ways to convert one base pair
to another base pair and that minimize
unwanted editing at off target locations
in cells is very important and engaging
with other scientists doctors ethicists
and governments to maximize the
likelihood that base editing is applied
thoughtfully safely and ethically
remains a critical obligation these
challenges notwithstanding if you had
told me even just five years ago that
researchers around the globe would be
using laboratory evolved molecular
machines to directly convert an
individual base pair to another base
pair at a specified location in the
human genome efficiently and with a
minimum of other outcomes I would have
asked you what science fiction novel are
you reading thanks to a relentlessly
dedicated group of students who were
creative enough to engineer what we
could design ourselves and brave enough
to evolve what we couldn't base editing
has begun to transform that science
fiction like aspiration into an exciting
new reality one in which the most
important gift we give our children may
not only be three billion letters of DNA
but also the means to protect and repair
them thank you
[Applause]